we turn now to a case in florida
involving a man who was released from
prison after one judge said he was
wrongly convicted of murder only to have
a higher court now threaten to send him
back to prison a taste of freedom that
may be short-lived
[Laughter]
a tearful homecoming after 32 years in
prison for a murder he says he did not
commit crosley greene had been set free
but the one good thing i can tell you
about my feelings that there's no hatred
[Applause]
and since i've been home
i felt a lot of love
was convicted in 1990 of the murder of
22 year old charles chip flynn based on
the testimony of flynn's girlfriend
the investigators
believed a
scared teenage story that there was a
black guy involved
in what may have been a tragic accident
but
there was no black guy
the girlfriend picked out green from
this police photo spread he was the one
on the middle of the top row
crosby's picture was in what prosecutors
and police officers called the bullseye
it was smaller it was darker it stuck
out like a store thumb and so if someone
was going to pick the black guy he was
the blackest guy was surrounded by
five light-skinned african-american men
that looked nothing
like him
but a federal judge ruled last year that
green did not get a fair trial back in
1990 that the prosecution withheld key
evidence from the defense that would
have pointed to the girlfriend
so you really think the girlfriend just
made out the story about a quote some
black guy
yes not only do i think that but the
first police officers on the scene
believed that as well and told the
prosecutors and all the investigators
that there wasn't any black guy and that
the girl did it
but
and even though this was taken down in
notes and memorialized those notes were
never turned over to the fence
presley green celebrated with his family
one of his first requests was to have
ice cream with his lawyers
but the celebration may have been
premature
the ruling overturning his conviction
was itself overturned by the 11th
circuit federal court of appeals
so now crosley greene could be sent back
to prison
and we're joined now by crosley green mr
green thank you so much for being here
this is quite an ordeal for you more
than a year now a taste of freedom but
the prospect that you may have to go
back to prison
first and foremost uh um thank you for
the head
doing this with me
well
yes it's
convenient it's a convenient thing where
it's a possibility i could go back to
prison
and how do you approach that how do you
think about that having spent three
decades behind bars
i don't think about it
i don't think about that but the good
lord above
the faith i have and the things that
i've accomplished since i've been home
with families friends
co-workers
and stuff like that
i i don't have time to think about
what is what i just got to keep moving
forward
will you keep your faith even if you are
ordered back to prison
there's no way i must
take my faith and just drop it throw it
out the door anything like that
i i made it this far i'm go i know i
just know i'm gonna make it
green's legal team is now launching a
public campaign to highlight his plight
it is a tragedy
um and it's you know these are cases
that are generally referred to as the
racial hoax cases where something
happens and you know they say a black
guy did it and the black guy gets
convicted well that's exactly what
happened here and it is a tragedy and
we're hopeful
that uh you know eventually justice will
be will be served and the 11th circuit
will review this case
and rule that prosecutors can't withhold
evidence of innocence
that's what this case is all about and
it's really important you mentioned the
south you're right
the 11th circuit covers the deep south
it is even more important
for prosecutors to have clear lines of
what they're supposed to do and what
they're not supposed to do under the
constitution
and that's that's what's so important
about this case
there were three witnesses who said that
your client mr green confessed to the
murder
yes yes that is unfortunately true and
all three of them have recanted that
testimony
and
that's important and the courts
often look uh with disdain on recanted
testimony
but this case is a little bit different
because uh the brevard county
prosecutor's office before they
prosecuted mr greene prosecuted three
other people
with similar jailhouse confessions
and those three other people were later
exonerated
those jail house confessions were
demonstrated to be just as false as the
jailhouse confessions that um you know
contributed to mr greene's
conviction
among those stepping forward to support
crosley greene is one of the police
officers from the original investigation
diane clark
when i put a badge on i took an oath to
serve and protect the community and that
meant all community in this particular
case with crosley green the truth was
hidden
and to me that's a travesty of justice
he spent half his life in prison for
something
that i don't believe he did
and i hope the right the wrong can be
righted you're not angry at the
prosecutors who uh withheld evidence
that might have exonerated you
no
no
i'm not hanging
i'm not much angry at kim hill hilla
i'm not much angry at
stuff that has happened
that i'm not gonna speak about doing the
case and stuff like that but
i looked back at it and there was reason
some things had happened
you know
for protection-wise or something like
that
you know so that went against me but i'm
not angry
let me ask you how do you account for
your client's continued hope and
optimism in the face of
what appears to be such a miscarriage of
justice
my client is one of the most amazing
people i've ever met
um things he has faced that would
destroy most humans
um
he just has overcome
based entirely on his faith in god and
it's a beautiful thing it's
inspirational to me it's inspirational
to
my entire legal team
so you still have hope
yes i got man i got i got great hope i
got like i said i got more faith in
anything i don't
sit around and
drama and then like that when my family
come around me
they ask me this or ask me that listen i
ain't got time for that i ain't thinking
about that i'm here with y'all now i'm
here i'm hoping to stay here with y'all
forever
a spokesperson for the prosecutor's
office in brevard county florida told us
none of the original prosecutors are
still working there and pointed us to
the ruling of the 11th circuit court
which said the evidence of crossley
green's guilt was quote compelling
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law on crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined now
by the editor-in-chief aidan mclaughlin
and mediaite of course like the law and
crime trial network is part of the dan
abrams media group and aidan you've
chosen as the winner this week the
reporters at political with their big
scoop on the draft of the supreme court
ruling on roe versus wade including josh
kirsten who talked about how they
verified the draft
well we're very confident in the uh
authenticity of this draft majority
opinion uh rachel both in the way that
we obtained it and other information
that we got that supports uh its
authenticity and makes us believe that
it is genuine now of course it's not a
final opinion it's a draft opinion it
was circulated in the court as a first
draft by justice alito in february dated
february 10th uh so it is possible there
have been some changes since then but
it's our our best understanding of at
least where the court stood at that time
so aidan this was a major scoop almost
nothing like this ever before that's
right um i've heard some people call it
the scoop of the decade um it was comes
from josh kirsten and alexander ward
both uh reporters at politico
josh carson was at abc he was a white
house and a china correspondent before
alexander ward used to be at vox they
both now work at politico in pretty
serious reporting positions they were
leaked this draft supreme court opinion
which would essentially overturn roe v
wade
and end federal protections for abortion
in the united states it is a massive
scoop they wrote in the piece i have the
line here that no draft decision in the
modern history of the court has been
disclosed publicly while a case is still
pending
so it's a pretty shocking scoop all
around they also did a very good job of
protecting their source
if you looked at the document that they
published on politico of this draft
decision there was no metadata that
could trace the document back to their
source
now the supreme court which has
confirmed that this draft opinion is
legitimate has started an investigation
to find out who the leaker is so this
story is going to continue but it's a
really phenomenal scoop from these two
veteran reporters and is the big story
the leak or the substance of the draft
opinion uh i don't think it's the leak
that's for sure um it's that's certainly
the bigger story for us at mediaite
because we cover the media and um and
that's sort of our focus obviously roe v
wade getting overturned is a much more
significant news story um no matter
whether or not you know republican
conservative pundits or politicians try
to distract by really focusing on the
leak and calling for prosecutions of the
leaker despite the fact that there
doesn't really seem to be a crime uh
directly associated with leaking a
supreme court draft decision right and
for this week's losers you've chosen
maria bartiroma of fox news who
apparently was giving advance a warning
to the white house about questions she
would ask donald trump
mr president you've said many times that
this election was rigged that there was
much fraud and the facts are on your
side let's start there please go through
the facts characterize what took place
so questions in advance aid right so
that interview maria bartorono conducted
with former president donald trump a few
weeks after the 2020 election which he
lost and you'll notice there that she
said that the facts are on his side
about the election being rigged which of
course as we know now and as we knew
then was complete nonsense now at the
time uh media uh managing editor joe
depaulo wrote a piece that said that
that interview for maria brodaromo
marked her day her the end of her days
as a journalist she was once a revered
journalist at fox news um and now has
sort of devolved into a conspiracy
theorist
now we know uh via the texts uh that
have been released through the january 6
commission that maria bartoroma was
actually sending mark meadows who was
trump's chief of staff at the time
questions in advance of the interview
she sent that question in particular to
meadows
and also with with a request that she
the meadows make sure that trump does
not go off on tangents in the interview
so you have a anchor at a news network
not only sending questions to a subject
before an interview but also begging the
subject's chief of staff to remain on
point
so a really really big journalistic
failure all around there
and also shows the extent to which fox
news hosts do not trust donald trump uh
to stay on message and to the notion of
this fair and balance the fox slogan i
mean i think i think it lays wasted that
a while ago this is yet further uh
evidence of how silly that is and also i
should note that fox news the network is
not commenting on this they've remained
silent on these texts so far all right
aidan mclaughlin thank you so much for
being with us here this evening and
thanks to all of you for joining us once
again on brian ross investigates we'll
see you back again next week right here
[Applause]
you